love this guy um enjoyed his call last
night um and i'm not just saying that
because i'm held captive to it uh
listening to the broadcaster uh well
because i do the the pregame and and
halftime of uh monday night football and
westwood one we just wrapped up the
season finale for the regular season on
that we'll be doing the uh um
i'll be doing the playoff game in a
couple playoffs in a couple of mondays
now
uh and he does the game with kevin
harlan and of course he's one of my best
friends i consider him such uh as i sit
right down a row from him on nfl game
day morning he's pro football hall of
famer kurt warner how are you doing kurt
i am doing really well my friend how are
you and i'm doing fine do you consider
rich one of your best friends cause
that's always an interesting thing like
rich considers you a best friend
but are you his best friend
of course i do you know we talk every
monday
you know like you said down the the uh
the row from each other
yeah he came to the premiere i did come
to the premiere
yeah i was there for him all right were
you there for him well i didn't get
invited oh boy
[Laughter]
well i guess you're not one of his best
friends
you know
then i was just recounting i was just
recounting about how we were there that
opening night and and uh you're
you're telling the matrix you know
you're stiff arm in the matrix right now
in the box office kurt this is pretty
cool you know it's it's it's been good
it's been fun and and
as you know movies kind of like this is
about word of mouth as much as anything
when people see it and people enjoy it
and um you know they tell their friend
and they tell their friend and that's
really what's happened is that everybody
that's gone and seen it has really
really enjoyed the movie um as you know
a little bit different than maybe what
you expect when you go in but
football fans non-football fans and that
to me was the true test is when you have
people that are non-football fans or you
know you have people tweet you yeah i
got drugged to the movie by
my husband or my friend or whatever and
then they came out of the thing loving
the movie that's when you know you've
got a good movie that it that it touches
everybody especially people that are
going when they don't really want to go
they don't think they're going to enjoy
it then they come out of the theater
enjoying it yeah you've come a long way
since those uh
those 100 touchdown bonuses with the
barnstormers right
you know a long way a long way but you
know incentive bonuses are always good
no matter where you're at in life
pretty much
absolutely uh all right so let's just
jump into it
what are you what do you make of baker
mayfield right now um after this season
that does appear to be over he's already
talking about you know how banged up his
surgery is coming and he may not play
the final game
what do you see when you see baker
mayfield well i mean i think you
see a guy that
has all kinds of potential and you see a
guy that has shown you moments
of
you know saying hey i can i can be elite
at this level but you see a guy that's
been majorly inconsistent um
with all of those things
i believe cleveland says hey we've got
the leader that we want
off the field a guy that you know is
going to be the same guy a tough guy a
guy that could he was going to stand in
there and you just talked about all the
things that he's been through this year
he's going to be there and he's going to
show up and he's going to battle and
lead his team and he's not going to shy
away from the criticism all the stuff
that you want from your franchise guy
off the field
the question becomes can you give us
that same sort of consistency
on the field and
you know you got to figure out what you
put your finger on what exactly is it
when you see those moments there's a
couple of them last night where he just
made some big time throws where you just
like and a guy in your face and it's a
second level throw and you see all the
ability and you go
why can't we get that every single time
every game um you know you got to ask
yourself what the team that he's got i i
look at baker mayfield and i say to
myself baker mayfield
if he's going to be that next level in
the nfl
he's going to have to be in an offense
where he can make
difference-making throws with his arm
but probably not asked to make 40 throws
with his arm because that consistency
hasn't been there you know accuracy-wise
and decision-making to do that but he
can make those big time throws and so i
maybe i look at a guy like uh carson
lynch um and where he's at this year and
you you see it you know a couple uh
sundays ago on christmas when we called
that game i mean he made one a throw
that i mean i still when i think back to
it i'm like man i can't even believe he
took the opportunity to throw it and not
only that he made the throw and you go
baker's got that in him
but
i don't know if he can be
you know an aaron rodgers type guy a tom
brady type guy that you know that you
can lean on in every given moment and
you also got to look at the team that
they've got i was talking about a little
bit last night and you say to yourself
okay who's the guy that we have that we
can count on
when we're throwing the football
you know to give us those big plays to
to consistently make the catch or get
open and make the game easier for your
quarterback
and right now i don't believe they have
that guy on offense either and so we're
gonna throw it all on baker um but i
don't know if they have the pieces
whether baker's the right guy or they
have the pieces around him
to say that they can be a throw first
type football team anywhere in the near
future well i mean odell was supposed to
be that guy right but that's that's who
they got that's who that guy was
supposed to be and the fact that he's
not there and now making fingertip
catches on fourth down leading to
touchdown
uh winning catch uh game-winning catches
uh for the rams in the very week in
which we just saw the browns be
eliminated from play before they even
took the field last night uh makes you
just wonder
is it the quarterback and and and i've
been the one who's been pounding this
very table right here from the show and
caping for for baker
and uh the time unfortunately of saying
he could be the guy is is kind of up
because there's one year to go and you
gotta sit here and say first overall
pick
uh quarterbacks who get a second
contract that usually starts with a high
three or a low four
in terms of an annual salary so what do
you do if you're cleveland making this
evaluation right now kurt if you were
that guy
yeah the bottom line is you're not
making that decision right now and if
you have to
you can't give him that contract you
know he hasn't shown that he can be the
guy to the point where you can
you know like you said the 30s or the
40s um and give him that sort of
contract especially when i look at this
team and i say you need a lot more on
this team
to compete for a championship so you got
to spend that money in other places um
and so yeah can they hold out this
entire next year as they've got that
fifth year option
and see
if he you know if he becomes that guy
and becomes more consistent and then
make that decision or is this kind of
one of those things like we're going to
play out this fifth year and maybe baker
will want to go somewhere else and and
you know we won't have the opportunity
to do that but i don't think you can
make that decision until you see
one full consistent gear from him at the
quarterback spot and and i say all that
looking from from a big picture let's
also remember this is cleveland and he's
done some things in these few years and
taken with the playoffs last year
that quarterbacks haven't done in
cleveland for a long long long time so
he has shown us that he can be better
than a lot of guys they had
but that becomes the question that a lot
of these teams face is is that good
enough for us to pay that kind of money
to a guy that's better than what we've
had but
not a guy we feel that will win us a
championship right now would you give
that money kurt warner here on the rich
either joe would you give that money to
lamar
the ravens have yet to do that uh he it
looks like he can't finish the season
um and i know he's an mvp guy and he had
a mvp first half of the season
but uh what do you think of his
evaluation because alan's gotten it and
we know darnold's not going to get it
and obviously josh rosen needs to find a
spot where he can prove whatever he he
can
what do you think
i believe lamar has shown us a level of
consistency that yes you can warrant
that big contract for lamar obviously
the mvp
they've won a lot of football games when
he's in there their their playoff team
year in and year out and so that to me
says yes you can call him a franchise
quarterback i still want to see more
from him before i'm convinced
he's a championship quarterback that he
can you know play in the pocket and play
away from his strengths
to a level
that i believe can compete with the
mahomes and and those types of guys
but you know he's still learning we knew
coming in that that was going to be the
part of his game that he was going to
have to learn and grow in
and he's done so much outside of that to
say while he's learning that we will
still win games and so yeah i think
lamar is a guy that uh has proven
that he will be that guy
athletically a guy that can carry you
the leader that you know everybody loves
him
and will battle form in the organization
that that it warrants getting that big
contract in a different way than you
know than what baker's done kurt warner
here on the rich eisen show i'm going to
give you a sports talk radio set up here
and you tell me if i'm right uh or you
would believe this let's take everybody
from the draft class of 2018 that we
just mentioned and then kyler murray in
his draft class right
and then uh 2020 and 2021 and let's even
throw in what we're gonna see
this year whoever that might be
the best quarterback to be coming out of
all that
winds up five years from now as joe
burrow would you believe that kurt
warner 100
100
and you know
i think the other there's going to be
other guys you know lamar and kyler
we talked about that josh allen
josh allen which do some some really
flashy things because athletically
you know they're at another level than a
joe burrow but
i've said this for years and i'm sure
i'm a little bit biased because i played
the game this way
but i just believe if you can play the
game mentally inside the pocket
that you will always be good at the
position if you can do that now all the
extra stuff you got to give me some
extra stuff to be a great quarterback
but if you can do that
you will always be good at the position
and joe burrow is doing that at an elite
level uh he's doing that he's got some
elite players around him which as i know
very well that plays a huge part in
being able to reach your potential if
you're a pocket passer you better have
some guys around you that you know can
accentuate what you do and they have
those guys
um and i've seen it from the start too
you know when i watched him play last
year um
you know you talk we talk a lot about
mac jones and in the way that he's
played as a rookie i saw all this stuff
from joe burrow and you saw the little
bit extra and the leadership and the
attitude and the toughness
that he brings to the table and so i
would not be surprised one bit
if we're saying i mean i think there's
some people that are already talking
about him in that category of being a
top five quarterback right now um and uh
you know we've seen the last couple
weeks i mean what over 900 yards passing
and big play after big play and
i really like joe burrow so that
statement would
100 percent uh in my mind could be an
accurate statement uh a couple years
down the road he's so good isn't he i
mean he really very good really is and
there's something about culture changing
too that's not easy i mean you can't
just snap your fingers
but having jamar chase sitting there
outside inside all over the place
that guy is amazing he's run away from
the ravens defense he's run away from
the chiefs defense
how deep do you think the bengals can go
this year right now kurt what do you
think
first of all you always have to ask
yourself can they beat anybody yes i
think they can beat anybody i mean the
show they can beat the chiefs i believe
they're you know they've got enough
talent and enough explosiveness that
they could beat anybody where they've
struggled this year
is
when they haven't been able to generate
the big plays
uh they haven't quite been consistent
enough especially in the front areas you
know offensive line defensive line
to
be able to work the football and score
points and stay up with people in those
situations
so that to me is going to be the
question come playoff time you know can
they live in the big play world and if
they can because they've got all those
playmakers around them yeah i think they
can make a run and they can beat anybody
in the playoffs
but
you know i'm still i'm not sitting here
saying they're one of my favorites to to
go to the super bowl because i have seen
a number of games where they've really
struggled in those areas and and haven't
put it all completely together yet so
good team beat everybody um
not quite sure they're a championship
team at this point all right so we're
about ten days away from that mulligan
that we get on game day morning that we
were afforded on thanksgiving day of our
pre-season
um super bowl picks who did you choose
again i don't recall that's not a joke i
actually i actually picked buffalo
and actually the cardinals at that i
think that's what was what i finished up
with and you stuck with that you stuck
with that at thanksgiving
no i think that's what i switched to
with thanksgiving the last time the last
time we went to all right so
what do you think in 10 days from now um
well yeah 10 days from now right now i i
i'm going to give the chiefs the
advantage in the afc you still have if
if i've got yeah if i've got to pick
somebody just
believe that they're going to be the
most consistent they're going to be a
team that can beat you on both sides
uh and then they got that guy at
quarterback that's that's been there and
done that i'm going to go there in the
afc side even though i you know
the titans at home they get king henry
back that's going to be a fun matchup
because i i like the way they're playing
you know the the bills and the bengals
we talked about on the show both have
beaten the chief so i i still think it's
wide open but i'll give the edge there
to the chiefs and on the other side i
would go green bay i can't remember when
we did our redos if anybody picked green
bay on the nfc side
but
i just they've been the most consistent
team they've had the most consistent
quarterbacks and they get home field
advantage and so those are three things
to me that it's what the playoffs are
all about is you know can you win
different ways
your quarterback do you know what you're
going to get uh and have you shown that
you can do it week in and week out and
the packers have and so right now
you know as open and wide open as both
conferences are
i look at my look at this and say i
think the two best teams uh at this
point in time are the chiefs and the
packers the thing that's really crazy
kurt is that there's obviously one guy
that's standing in the way of green bay
and you know i'm talking to you a night
after you're calling a game that's the
final game at home of a guy
who you played in a super bowl against
right like big ben's big ben's coming
now he's about to go
you're a hall of famer now with a movie
in theaters near you about you and
brenda and your whole family's life
and the guy that's standing in the way
is a guy who prevented you from winning
your second super bowl
and he's now 44 years old and we can't
discount him it's insane it really is
nuts every single time you try to put
tom brady in perspective
so
where do you stand on all that and i
know again they're banged up antonio
brown i don't think that's going to
leave a lingering mark on them like it
did say the raiders when he uh imploded
there or i mean brady's been through
losing brown before
in new england so um i don't
i don't know what do you make of the
bucks right now and everything going on
there
i think they're still dangerous um i
think their defense has the capabilities
of taking over um you know watch that
game against the jets last week with
brady and there was a couple throws in
that game that i had to go back and
rewind again and just kind of go
dang it really he he made those throws
you know at this age
and so
you know godwin's gonna hurt he's a
difference maker because he does
different things
but get mike evans back the tight ends
and the way that they can play
ronald jones even if you know playoff
lenny isn't able to be 100 percent i
like ronald jones i think he's a really
really good back um and should have
played more all year long and then
they've got some young receivers that
are coming into their own that you know
that can be some difference makers on
the outside so
yeah i i will not discount them one bit
in the big moment with that guy behind
center and with the team that they have
i mean they've got a lot of really good
pieces on that team that i believe can
compete with anybody and so yeah they've
been you know knocked down a little bit
the last couple weeks
but
yeah i mean i know everybody in the nfc
you can look at a lot of different teams
you're definitely going to know where
number 12 is and how they're playing and
whether you've got to play them in the
play x or not because
yeah they're still right up there in my
my opinion kurt you're the best you know
look everyone knows you're pure in terms
of your intensity in terms of your
commitment in terms of everything and in
case they
you know they they've forgotten about it
i'm not talking about the movie in
theaters near you i'm talking about the
fact that you wore that shiny jacket
again last night
and uh you just you're just you're just
gonna you only know one speed you know
what i mean kurt yeah that's right you
know you gotta you gotta bring it you
gotta always bring it no matter what the
situation and uh no matter what people
say on twitter you bring it and i'll be
there to bring it so anytime i got a
cold weather city that i'm going to
you may just see the shiny silver jacket
now is that another way of saying brenda
pick this for you or like what's the
history what's the history it sounds
anything like brenda picked that for me
i don't know kurt it's just you know i i
all i know is if i wore something on the
air that trended
and it wasn't susie supported the second
time around nothing be gone and that
thing would be history that thing would
be at the center of the earth right now
definitely brenda supported okay so i
definitely got the stamp of approval
from brenda
and uh and she's all she's all for it
yes okay all right what did you say
chris so you picked it out you're taking
ownership of this decision
well yeah you know
[Applause]
he's the american underdog chris
yes
fighting against odds
effort in the warner house yes you're
going to the movie so you're going to
rally behind this jacket and you're
going to win games
you're going to rally around the jacket
thanks for the call kurt i appreciate it
you bet buddy all right talk to you so
sunday so saturday see you saturday
there's a good skirt one everybody
thanks again
you're gonna rally around the chat how's
it going chris
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here